tahiti
à lévis
les cow boys band tout
par delà les nuages la municipalité de
rome à draper de noir vous le voyez les
statuts de la célèbre fontaine de trevi
en signe de deuil après la disparition
de marché low mastroianni qui avait
tourné là en 1960 la scène la plus
célèbre de la dolce vita
ce monstre sacré du cinéma italien y
mort ce matin à l'âge de 72 ans à paris
des suites d'un cancer du pancréas vie
privée catherine deneuve qui fut
longtemps sa compagne et leur fille
chiara se trouvaient toutes deux au
chevet de l'acteur ce matin à son
domicile parisien rue de seine reporta
fille visseyrias dida elle est restée
auprès de lui jusqu'au dernier moment en
début d'après midi
catherine deneuve quitte le 91 rue de
seine
sans un mot derrière elle sa fille
chiara mastroianni
elle aussi a passé toute la nuit au
chevet de l'acteur aujourd'hui seuls la
famille et les amis intimes ont pu
rentrer c'est au cinquième étage de cet
immeuble derrière ses fenêtres closes
que s'est éteint ce matin marcello
mastroianni marco ferreri son ami intime
sera l'un des seuls à concéder quelques
mots
toujours plus d'aller manger pas des
mots aujourd'hui
c'est les journées pire vous fait
au cours de la journée d'autres proches
comme claudia cardinale viendront lui
rendre un dernier hommage
ces derniers temps marcello mastroianni
tête entouré de tous ses amis pour
lutter contre son cancer téléphone
jusqu'à la dernière minute il on
attendait avec milliards semaines dit
chow
il était très malade et pouvait plus
bouger et ils avaient la force des
mollets dans le quartier la disparition
de marcello mastroianni laisse un grand
vide
tout le monde ici apprécié l'homme
autant que l'acteur
dans lequel il joue et j'en parlais hier
soir j'ai l'impression que ya beaucoup
de choses qui sont souvent mal qu il
vient très courtois et poli avec nous
et très gentil sud demain 15 heures les
parisiens sont invités à venir se
recueillir à l'église saint sulpice
trois vies et une seule mort titre
prémonitoire pour le dernier film tourné
par marcello mastroianni en réalité plus
de 150 vie pour cet acteur qui a
participé en effet à plus de 150 films
et qui avant de découvrir le monde du
cinéma avait fait pratiquement tous les
métiers pour survivre hommage signé
pascal deschamps
arias
cette fois la cage des images pour
l'éternité dans tous tant qu'il y aura
des films et des hommes pour s'en
souvenir
ce sont ces images de la dolce vita de
marcello mastroianni laissera sans doute
dans leur mémoire
ou peut-être celle-ci fellini encore ou
celle là le casanova vieillissant
d'ettore scola arbitraire mémoire pour
une des carrière les plus étonnantes de
ce demi siècle
cent trente six films en cinquante ans
stakhanoviste des tournages marcello
mastroianni a voulu se glisser dans
toutes les plus modestes il disait lors
d'une de ses dernières interviews
j'avais découpé avec milieu super quand
on joue et on avait beaucoup mieux que
moi moi rien ne destinait le petit
mastroianni avec un j qu'il abandonnera
plus tard ou septième art à 19 ans il
votre petit boulot en petit boulot mais
sèche le bureau pour courir au centre
théâtrales universitaires
à force de vanter les studios il
décroche un premier rôle dans l'évadé du
bagne enchaîne les apparitions au
théâtre et au cinéma
rien ne destinait marcello au métier
d'acteur sinon une terrible envie de
faire lui aussi partie du rêve sur
celluloïd à l'époque
en 1960 la dolce vita le révèle au monde
les offres pleuvent il refuse celle
d'hollywood il faut dire que visconti
fellini encore avec huit et demi ici
mais aussi antonio nîmes scola se
l'arrachent arbitraire de la mémoire
encore mastroianni devient jeune premier
malgré lui il est le let in over le
séducteur letombe continue vous savez à
parler de ses succès auprès des femmes
et à moi vraiment ça ne m'est jamais
arrivé je vous assure
j'aimerais bien voir toute cette jeune
fille venir déchaîné me demander un
autographe
comme elles le font avec d autres
acteurs oui on parle beaucoup de ses
succès auprès des fans
moi moi je crois que c'est encore un
beau mythe
une image qu'il n'aura de cesse de
détruire
en devenant par exemple le premier roman
fin de l'histoire dans l'événement le
plus important depuis que l'homme a
marché sur la lune ou en composant dans
une journée particulière
l'un des plus beau personnage
d'homosexuel du cinéma un homosexuel
autant de mussolini et l'un de ses plus
beaux rôles face à une autre star qui
jouait elle aussi avec son image sophia
loren et moi mais aussi à l'improviste
comme externe ou un seul mot d'ordre
faire passer mission et puis surtout
surtout s'amuser voire provoquer comme
marco ferreri l'entraînent dans l'
aventure de la grande bouffe ou quand il
dit oui à bertrand blier dans un deux
trois soleil il était le père
d'alcooliques d'anouk grinberg à la
retombée en enfance et mon père ce
qu'est la une de l'avenir ce chercheur
en classe alors qu'il pourrait être si
bien au bistrot en train de siroter son
pastis pour amuser s'amuser et surtout
ne jamais faire croire que c'était
difficile je n'aime pas les légendes
qu'en fait si les acteurs quand ils
disent qu'il souffre avec l'air
conditionné l'été nous amène un studio
tous les mois vous dit bonjour vous avez
bien dormi kaka tout le travail de
prérégler bien à vous voulez un café et
vous maquille je m'endors généralement
parce que le matin on est encore un
petit peu comme ça puis toute la lumière
autour du miroir
les types qui vous fait un massage
j'adore ma maman à bijoux ne tient la
tête quand indices presse j'aimerais du
pied qui à ce jour
ce jeune premier aimant tout à raser la
leçon à lisbourg mène à la maison vous
avez gagné des radiants quelques oies ou
tomber même un auto mais amoureux de
l'actrice et sont toujours de belles
filles quel métier de merde
oh
certains passent leur temps à travestir
des mensonges lui avait l'art de mentir
pour faire passer un peu de vérité de
l'autre côté du miroir
une journée particulière en italie où
l'émotion est bien sûr très forte avec
lui c'est le coeur du cinéma italien qui
s'en va a déclaré dino risi avant les
obsèques dimanche à rome le corps de
marcello mastroianni sera exposé près du
palais du capitole où siège le
gouvernement italien à rome pour france
2 alain de chalvron ce soir la fontaine
de trevi s'est mise en deuil
cette fontaine symbole de mastroianni de
la dolce vita de ses heures de gloire du
cinéma italien cérémonie spontanée
décidée par le maire de rome francesco
route elle dans l'après-midi cérémonie
civique hâtive de la secousse ressentie
par l'itf à l'annoncé de la mort de
l'acteur ceci est un message de mémoire
d'affection de reconnaissance de la
ville de rome en masse torriani croyait
arrivée au bras du réalisateur francesca
rossi était là pour témoigner je savais
qu'il était mal que peut-on faire c'est
la vie
on a perdu un immense acteur et on a
perdu un homme unique
unique dans sa vérité dans sa simplicité
dans sa façon d'être ce matin la
fontaine symbole fonctionner encore pour
les touristes à peine la nouvelle de la
mort de mastroianni connu les jets d'eau
se sont arrêtés on a ordonné de fermer
la fontaine pour la mort de mastroianni
mutuellement
le père noël de la place à continuer à
faire son métier mais le coeur n'y était
plus oui j'ai eu un coup au coeur parce
que mastroianni il s'était véritablement
un grand acteur
soleil le symbole de l'italie dans le
cinéma l or moi aujourd'hui je suis très
triste
beaucoup parmi les visiteurs du foie
arrêter des admirateurs de l'acteur
disparu ou des amis comme mimo la
rupture aussi l'incontournable
assistante du cinéma italien
on m'a dit qui a paris je l' ai vu un
pic adam le deuxième pièce qu'il a fait
à paris il fallait de mourir à noël avec
une grande arbres et mis cela très
content des mourides haut à noël il est
mort à mon nom
c'est toujours triste de la lumière
c'est là ce soir devant la fontaine
leurs caisses de la police municipale a
interprété une musique triste d'un film
de fellini
en espérant que quelque part mastroianni
pourra l'entendre
la cité des femmes a perdu aujourd'hui
un grand séducteur marcello mastroianni
a eu en effet une vie sentimentale très
riche avec de nombreuses passions et
plusieurs enfants à l'écran comme dans
la vie il a tenu dans ses bras les plus
jolies femmes commentaires jean-jacques
du si marcello adoré claudia cardinale
il n'aimait pas l'étiquette de séducteur
son actrice préférée c'était sophia
loren avec elle il a tourné des films là
c'est une journée particuliers haut
parleurs blagueur nostalgique tendre
c'était surtout un charmeur les vrai
séducteur disette ils sont héroïques
viril et ils ont un grand nez moi je
suis nous et j'ai un petit nez
ce mode est séducteur malgré lui se
foutait de son aspect physique l'âge les
rides l'estomac
normal avec l'âge
est-ce qui est elle-même son dernier
film qui sort le 25 décembre s'intitule
on n'en parle pas et c'est une chronique
d'un amour passionné extravagant et
provoquant
nous nous sommes tant aimés parmi ces
femmes de rêve monica vitti avec qui
mastroianni avait tourné dans la nuit
film d'antonioni notre correspondant à
rome la rencontre est tout à l'heure
pour moi un grand dam est un personnage
incroyable de fantasy de douceur parce
que match à l'hôtel aussi douce et si on
peut dire celeno que fois il s'amusait à
jouer à voir tout le monde
c'est un ami c'est un personnage
inoubliable c'était la fantasy
quand on a tourné ensemble on s'amusait
aussi beaucoup s'amuser on a joué on a
on ne le sont pas j'ai passé le travail
comme un roman comme un jeu peu plus
chaud kapissa il s'amusait pas quand il
était à nous y est pour quelque chose il
a dormi là comme ça une façon de penser
à quelque chose et rester là comme ça et
tout ce qu il domine pour je ne sais pas
combien de temps
c'était tellement c'est les noms qui est
un grand acteur
la star c'est positif et négatif dans le
même temps parce qu'elle est positive ce
teen star une étoile donc il était une
toile star mais il avait la l'humanité
qui était la chose la plus important ce
match elles ou le mal était normal et à
chaque fois il était aussi une grosse
pas
norm star mais lui dedans c'est un homme
en armes entre l cool il a exactement
nous reviendrons sur la disparition de
marcello mastroianni en fin de journal
sachez d'ores et déjà que france 2 a
décidé de bouleverser ses programmes
avec la diffusion ce soir vers 23h après
donc le magazine envoyé spécial du film
d'ettore scola une journée particulière
avec sophia loren
les autres titres de l'actualité avec
tout d'abord une vingtaine
d'interpellations à la suite
d'opérations de police menées dans les
milieux islamistes en région parisienne
ainsi qu'à roubaix dans le nord
reportage à n'ourgh michel field
l'irruption des hommes encagoulés en
gilet pare-balles a quelque peu perturbé
la tranquillité de ce quartier de
villeneuve la garenne
c'était leur but lissiers et au même
instant des dizaines de policiers
intervenus simultanément dans plusieurs
villes de la région parisienne dans cet
immeuble de villeneuve la garenne un
homme était surveillé depuis plusieurs
semaines par la police judiciaire et les
rg il est algérien
il a 35 ans il s'appelle salah il
intéresse les policiers parce qu'il est
en contact avec les membres du gang de
roubaix la sphère de roubaix c'est cette
fusillade au mois de mars dans laquelle
trois malfaiteurs avaient été tués et
deux hommes du raid blessés
une affaire de droit commun avait dit à
l'époque le ministre de l'intérieur au
vu du dossier aujourd'hui la réalité
paraît plus complexe
les membres du gang de roubaix était en
contact avec un réseau de fabricants de
faux papiers qui fournissait les
documents falsifiés à des islamistes
partis combattre en algérie
parmi les individus interpellés ce matin
plusieurs sont dans ce cas
en perquisitionnant à leur domicile les
policiers n'ont pas fait de découverte
spectaculaire une seule arme un fusil
avec une aide de vie
et des documents en langue arabe le coup
de filet a été lancée sur commission
rogatoire du juge bruguière
mais il n'a aucun lien avec l'attentât
de port-royal le fc canal historique qui
a revendiqué aujourd'hui la série
d'attaqués menées contre des
gendarmeries en corse ces trois derniers
jours a intensifié ses menaces contre
les forces de l'ordre présentes
actuellement dans l'île de beauté sur
place arnaud goûter jean-paul chaussée
un communiqué du flnc revendique ce soir
cet attentat commis en corse depuis le 7
décembre mais le mouvement clandestin
intensifie ses menaces contre les
gendarmes qui peuvent je cite se
considérer en état de guerre
une allusion directe à la fusillade
d'hier soir à 19h50 un homme mitraillent
la gendarmerie de saint florent aucune
victime n'est à déplorer mais les
gendarmes prennent en chasse le véhicule
du tireur et ouvrent le feu pour la
deuxième fois en 48 heures des gendarmes
corse riposte un mitraillage de brigade
les gendarmes agissent dans le cadre des
lois et des règlements il existe deux
textes qui permettent tout simplement la
légitime défense
sur cette route située à deux kilomètres
de saint florent les gendarmes ont
retrouvé le véhicule du tireur ses deux
occupants ont réussi à prendre la fuite
dans le maquis
une tâche de sang révèle que l'un d'eux
a été blessé le flnc dans son communiqué
déclare qu dorénavant ses commandos ne
prendront plus de risques inutiles
les gendarmes n'ont plus gilet
pare-balles et fusil à pompe
une cinquantaine d'entre eux quadrillé
ce matin un vaste périmètre autour de
saint florent protection identique dans
les 63 casernement de lille 13 cents
gendarmes vivent ici avec leur famille
des familles que le flnc avait récemment
conseiller d'évacuer au pérou deuxième
jour d'angoise pour plus de 400
personnes retenues en otage à
l'intérieur de l'ambassade du japon à
lima depuis maintenant quarante et une
heure par un commando d'une vingtaine
d'hommes d'extrême gauche qui exige la
libération de leur ami emprisonné le
point olivier lerner certains otages
commence à sortir de l'ombre comme
l'ambassadeur du canada au pérou depuis
24 heures il multiplie les
allers-retours entre la résidence de
l'ambassadeur du japon à lima toujours
le contrôle des guérilleros ce et la
présidence otages il a été choisi pour
négocier son espagnol est approximatif
mais suffisant pour établir un relais il
confirme que les preneurs d'otage ne
faiblissent pas ils réclament toujours
avec force la libération de 300 membres
de leur mouvement le conseiller culturel
français otages libérés a lui aussi été
désigné pour porter des messages
on n'a pas été maltraités simplement les
conditions notre détention cette journée
a été terrible surtout de vue
psychologique
voilà je pense qu'il y avait un certain
optimisme plus tôt heureusement
meilleure le nombre d'otages varie selon
les sources
400 selon les médiateurs parmi eux le
frère du président péruvien le chef de
la police antiterroriste péruvien et une
quarantaine de diplomates
la situation sanitaire est précaire
manque d espace pour dormir trop peu de
nourriture pour tenir de nombreux
militaires quadrillent les lieux mais
ont exclu à l'heure qu'il est une action
de force propriétaire des lieux le japon
s'y opposent
tant que les diplomates font la navette
c'est bon signe dit on les tractations
se poursuivent donc avec les
ambassadeurs du canada d'allemagne et de
grèce épaulé d'un péruvien et du
conseiller culturel français en poste à
lima ce mouvement révolutionnaire tupac
amaru est apparue au pérou dans les
années 80 il tient son nom d'un chef
indien qui avait mené un soulèvement
contre les colonisateurs espagnols à la
fin du xviiie siècle précision dorothée
olliéric philippe rochot il fait moins
20 degrés à la prison de yana maillot
pour combattre le mouvement des tupac
amaru le pouvoir péruvien a choisi le
froid c'est là que sont enfermés les
principaux militants dont les preneurs
d'otages demande la libération
ici les gardiens portent des cagoules
pour ne pas être reconnus par les amis
des terroristes ils seraient abattus
sans pitié le chef du mouvement victor
campos est détenu depuis quatre ans mais
son épouse rose à réfugié politique en
france le présente comme un homme qui se
bat pour la justice sociale
c'est quelqu'un qui en payera cliquant
de cultiver quelqu'un cache aussi
l'élite parce qu'il était convaincu
qu'il pouvait changer les choses son
pays
c'est quelqu'un que peut-être elle peut
avoir notre avenir
le calme pour tranquillité parce qu'il a
cru que c'est le pigiste le mouvement
tupac amaru recrutent surtout dans les
bidonvilles de lima depuis l'arrestation
de son chef il avait adopté un profil
bas ces combattants se réunissaient en
secret dans la banlieue de la capitale
pour apprendre le maniement des armes et
des explosifs
les tupac amaru se sont distingués par
des attaques de banque et d'ambassades
le mouvement a pu compter près de 500
militants au plus fort de son action ses
ennemis ne sont pas seulement les
militaires du régime fujimori
mais aussi les guérilleros du sentier
lumineux régulièrement ces groupes se
livrent bataille pour le contrôle de
l'impôt révolutionnaire chez les
trafiquants de drogue
leur discours politique à sommaire
vincere moss nous vaincrons du style
mais en quinze ans la guérilla au pérou
a fait plus de trente mille morts
cérémonie particulièrement émouvante ce
matin sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de
genève à être l'hommage officiel rendu
aussi collaborateur de la croix-rouge
assassinée en tchétchénie
durant leur sommeil dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi cérémonie en présence des
membres du cicr qui ont survécu à ce
massacre des familles des victimes et du
président de la croix rouge à paris
beaucoup de journalistes cet après midi
au palais de justice brigitte bardot
poursuivi pour incitation à la
discrimination raciale en effet tenu à
venir personnellement se justifier
devant les magistrats
le parquet a demandé une condamnation de
principe sur place denis verdeilhan
christian tu brigitte bardot fait encore
salle comble mais aujourd'hui c'est au
palais de justice on se presse on se
bouscule on veut la voir la toucher et
saisir la star sur la pellicule et ici
aussi difficile qu'à cannes
pas question de cinéma mais uniquement
de défense des animaux depuis 16 ans dit
bardot je me bats contre le sacrifice
rituel des moutons lors de la fête de
l'aïd al kébir
c'est peut-être une grande fête mais
pour moi c'est une horreur
dans l'article qui lui vaut ce procès le
président du tribunal note un dérapage
de l'ex actrice sur la présence des
musulmans en france et bardos persiste
je connais des pauvres dit elle qui pour
un poste de rmistes passe après les
musulmans quand on est admis dans un
pays on doit se conformer à ses lois
c'est le discours de la préférence
nationale du front national note la
partie civile et au tribunal elle confie
ses états d'âme j'envisage de quitter la
france si je continue de me sentir mal
dans ma peau
on l'a compris brigitte bardot a changé
de registre elle est passée de la
séduction à la provocation
xavière tiberi l'épousé du maire de
paris a été entendue ce matin pendant
environ trois heures par les deux juges
d'instruction d'evry en charge du
dossier concernant le rapport commandé
par à vis du one le président du conseil
général de l'essonne
xavière tiberi avait été mise en examen
au début de ce mois pour recel de
détournement de fonds publics
son avocat a précisé qu'elle n'avait pas
été placé sous contrôle judiciaire
d'autre part jean louis cambrai dont
deuxième vice président rpr du conseil
général de ce département l'essonne a
été écroués après avoir été mis en
examen dans une affaire de salaire à
supposés fictifs
l'ancien président de l'opéra de paris
pierre bergé a été condamné aujourd'hui
à dix mois de prison avec sursis à la
suite de l'effondrement d'un décor qui
avait fait un mort et 40 blessés lors
d'une répétition a sévi en 92 à rouen la
cour d'appel a ordonné le renvoi devant
la cour d'assises de jean marc deperrois
soupçonné d'avoir tué la petite emilie
avec du sirop de josacine empoisonnée au
cyanure devant le congrès du parti
communiste le secrétaire général de la
cgt a annoncé aujourd'hui officiellement
son départ du bureau national du parti
louis viannet brise ainsi une tradition
vieille d'un demi-siècle selon tous les
sondages la politisation de la cgt et
leurs proches numéro un a dressé par les
salariés sur place pour france 2
françoise david michel levasseur plus de
liberté d'action plus de liberté de
manoeuvre si ce qu'a réclamé le
secrétaire général de la cgt pour sa
confédération
dopé par le mouvement social de décembre
dernier louis viannet a voulu pousser
son avantage et coupé le cordon avec le
peu fait au parti le débat politique à
la cgt minutes
bref le partage du travail je suis
acharné permettant même au nom du mot
social d'un réseau social déterminé ces
revendications 500 ferment sans
souligner deux programmes de partie oui
un accord 1 en fait la cgt ne va plus se
retrouver pieds et poings liés
comment 80 si le pc est au gouvernement
en 98
réaction de robert e d'un commun accord
nous avons décidé effectivement que bon
lui pour forcément nécessaire qu'il soit
dans le bureau national robert hue
pourra toujours se consoler devraient
entrer au comité national l'un des
leaders des grèves de décembre
le très médiatique patron de la
fédération des cheminots bernard
thibault dernière ligne droite pour les
négociations unedic que patronat et
syndicats doivent en effet décider de la
répartition de l'excédent dégagé par
l'assurance chômage
plutôt une baisse des cotisations ou
plutôt une amélioration de
l'indemnisation des chômeurs laurent
besse coup de casque pour les à coups de
matraque pour les autres et jets de
projectiles divers
la fin de la manifestation des chômeurs
et surtout des intermittents du
spectacle a donc été marquée par
quelques heurts avec les cr depuis le
début de l'après midi
plus de 2500 personnes ont convergé vers
le cnpn beaucoup d'intermittents donc
qui ne veulent pas renoncer à leur
système de chômage qui leur garantit une
année d'indemnisation à taux plein dans
la rue c'est donc la pression à
l'intérieur du cnpf la négociation le
problème des intermittents sera réglé
d'ici quatre mois mais cette nuit c'est
le sort de la science chômage en général
qui sera tranchée car en 97 l'unedic
dégagera 13 milliards d'excédents le
patronat de les consacrer en majorité à
la baisse des cotisations des
entreprises et des salariés les
syndicats veulent que l'argent et
surtout aux chômeurs rendre aux salariés
une part des cotisations et aux
entreprises
la part qui leur revient est une façon
d'activer également une améliorerait end
contre le chômage on soit le père noël
soit dans cette maison est par contre on
y va avec la volonté déterminée de
défendre des intérêts des chômeurs
c'est ce que nous essaierons de reposer
en début de séance et tout au long de
cette errance faire que l'on puisse
sortir de cette négociation avec des
résultats concrets pour les chômeurs la
nuit risque d'être long pour les
négociateurs et pour les chômeurs qui en
attendait frud dehors elle a commencé
sous des auspices agité dedans les
antagonistes devront absolument trouver
un compromis en grande-bretagne le
nombre des chômeurs est repassé sous la
barre symbolique des deux millions
une statistique qui arrange le premier
ministre conservateur john mesure qui
est actuellement en campagne électorale
mais qui est cependant à prendre avec
précaution à langres pour france 2 et
inerte
le gouvernement britannique passera noël
au chaud moins de 2 millions de chômeurs
une consommation en forte hausse des
recettes de tva qui explosent et en
prime un rapport de l' ocde publié
aujourd'hui is it la grande bretagne en
exemple à l'adresse des pays voisins qui
écarquillent les yeux et se demande
comment font les anglais
les experts avancent deux explications
d'abord héritage des années thatcher un
patron peut ici embaucher et débaucher
comme il le souhaite
ce jeune diplômé d'hsc rédige les
contrats de travail de son entreprise
rien de plus simple je pense qu'en fort
serait pas capable de le faire ici vont
il faut préciser la date de départ le
salaire et c'est à peu près tout mon
frère on n'a pas sécurité du travail à
100% que le côté comme la tiare
conjoncture et simone qui il ya
énormément de places offertes
ensuite et le constat est moins rose le
mode de calcul des indemnisations à
rayer des listes en un mois 25 mille
chômeurs avec 1500 francs par mois on ne
pointe plus au chômage sans vraiment
gagner de quoi vivre
le fossé entre riches et pauvres et
d'après les nations unies le même en
grande-bretagne qu'au nigeria terroriste
dans ce pays il y a deux millions de
personnes à la recherche d'un emploi qui
ne figure pas dans les statistiques
officielles du chômage par exemple ceux
qui perçoivent une allocation de longue
durée et les femmes au foyer
john majeur ne boude pas son plaisir
l'économie britannique est un lion qui
rugit en europe se plaît-il à rappeler
en citant les quatre millions de
chômeurs allemands et les trois millions
de français sans emploi certes les modes
de calcul ne sont pas les mêmes mais en
tout cas pour l'instant la recette
anglaise semble être la plus efficace
pour créer des emplois
jacques chirac a visité ce matin le
nouveau siège du samu social à l'hospice
aussi gênant le 12e arrondissement de
paris le chef de l'état avait créé lui
même ce service destiné à soulager les
détresses de plus urgent lorsqu'il était
maire de paris
et ce matin jacques chirac a félicité
jean tiberi successeur à l'hôtel de
ville d'en perpétuer le bon
fonctionnement
l'occasion pour le président d'appeler
les parisiens à participer à cette
solidarité
les gens qui voient une personne en
détresse
surtout si celle ci un chien ce qui est
fréquemment le cas se détournent ce
n'est pas bien
si vous estimez ne pas pouvoir vous même
tendre la main parce que vous n'en avez
pas la compétence le goût au moins fait
le geste qui consiste à appeler et à
prévenir le samu social
en quoi consiste précisément le travail
des équipes de ce samu social reportage
vincent nguyen pascal stelletta l'heure
du briefing au samu social de paris
cette nuit quatre camions vont récupérer
en ville les sans domicile qui ont
appelé le numéro vert trois autres vont
faire ce qu'ils appellent la maraude
pas trop vite voilà comment il c'est de
voir les gens qui sont sur une touche de
chaleur ou sur un banc puis bon c'est
aller vers eux quoi aux côtés d'eric
dans le camion numéro 7
une infirmière et une travailleuse
sociale au fil des rencontres
il ya d'abord les habitués comme marcel
fait qu'on attend vous êtes dans la rue
la balade à un moment dire à s'en sortir
il y a aussi ce qu'il faut convaincre et
ceux qui sont perdus
rarement avant les deux semaines
c'est que du côté avant
tu habitais quelque part
c'est toujours que deux mandats
il s'appelle arthur il a très mal aux
dents c'est tout ce qu'il dira sur la
route qui l'emmène lui et quelques
autres au foyer de montrouge
demain il pourra rencontrer une
assistante sociale pour le moment il
faut parer au plus pressé
marcel lui s'est déjà mis au lit au
chaud enfin moi j'ai travaillé un nom
comme permanente au sommet social
j'avoue que sur le côté moral j'ai
beaucoup changé ça m'a pris à rencontrer
vraiment la misère la misère ici on n'en
mesure l'ampleur tous les jours jusqu'à
5 heures du matin voilà si vous avez un
cas de détresse à signaler donc qu'aux
équipes du samu social vous pouvez
appeler ce numéro vert donc gratuit le 0
800 306 306 signe des temps depuis
quelques années père noël rime avec
service audiotel un certain nombre de
lignes téléphoniques permettent à nos
chers bambins et bambine de converser
avec petit papa noël
le problème c'est que le dis papa noël
est très bavard et que c'est papa tout
court qui paie la facture
reportage florence bouvier jean claude
elfassi
et oui le père noël déborder un
secrétariat particulier et une stratégie
perfectionner pour faire durer la
conversation téléphonique le plus
longtemps possible
norman le père noël est vieux don dure
de la feuille glisse très et même
parfois un peu 2223 la minute
la communication est coupée après 20
minutes chaque appel coûte donc 44 ans
le père noël fait connaître ses numéros
de téléphone dans les suppléments télé
ou les journaux gratuits
généreux il promenait souvent des
cadeaux qu'ils parviennent rarement à
leurs destinataires
mais les factures du téléphone elle
s'alourdit inexorablement le père noël
du pas un acteur mais le il permet à
deux arnaqueurs de mieux vivre dans
cette affaire il ya d'abord le
propriétaire des serveurs bien
évidemment qui donne 50 % des
prélèvements et le reste à france
télécom france télécom dans cette
affaire étant juge et partie il ne
s'empresse pas de fermer ses serveurs
qui coûtent fort cher aux familles
décidément un prog 1 le père noël a
trouvé le moyen de gagner encore plus
d'argent pour les fondations éditeurs
comme dirait l'autre c'est pas pour me
vanter mais il a beaucoup neigé les
professionnels des sports d'hiver se
frotte les mains le cru 96-97 s'annonce
excellent c'est un hit en nous faut dire
que les français avaient plutôt tendance
à bouder la neige à noël
reportage à l'accusé benoît gallerey
thierry monnier c'est un peu comme un
cadeau de noël de la neige beaucoup de
neige sur le massif des aravis
à cet endroit il y avait seulement 15 cm
l'année dernière mais cette année il n'y
en a six fois plus 90 cm des vers la mi
décembre exceptionnel hockey du merle
ici à 15 100 m la neige est tombée en
abondance en oeuvre
ambre et à la clusaz il faut remonter à
1954 pour trouver une telle générosité
du ciel du coup les dameuses sont partis
à l'assaut des filles avec trois
semaines d'avant pour la plus grande
joie des premiers skieurs
essentiellement des gens du pays qui
après les années de manque redécouvre la
neige à noël les bonnes les mots là haut
un peu plus j'ai par là mais c'est le
fait c'est le fait et on est content on
a en haute savoie où l'imprévu s'appuie
moment du coup dans le village la
centrale de réservation est en pleine
ébullition
les chiffres sont à la hausse par
rapport à 95 20 % de plus dans les
agences et les hôtels nous avons eu un
saut de la réservation est aujourd'hui
nous refusons des clients pour la
semaine du jour de l'an les loueurs de
matériels surf également sur la vague et
chacun de présenter le plus beau parc
locatif
ici pas moins de 1000 paires de skis et
8 personnes recrutées pour satisfaire le
client quitte l'équipe est déjà l'un
formé les produits tout doit être en
place les fixations et laisse qui prend
tout en bloc d'un seul coup parce que
grâce à cette neige la neige ce qui ne
semble pas le seul facteur d'engouement
pour la montagne
il y aurait aussi est plus que jamais un
besoin impérieux de s'aérer la tête
c'est pour le client le meilleur moyen
de sortir un peu de son quotidien sa
grisaille bas c'est de venir ici au beau
soleil d'oublier pendant quelques jours
un peu tous les soucis des soucis les
professionnels de la montagne non plus
pour noël reste février toujours la
crainte des conséquences d'un éventuel
redoux
si vous avez pris ce journal en cours je
vous rappelle la principale nouvelle de
cette journée une triste nouvelle la
disparition à l'âge de 72 ans des suites
d'un cancer du comédien italien marcello
mastroianni un séducteur qui avaient
énormément de recul sur lui-même
portrait signé marie pierre farkas
mais si vous être généré mesdames et
messieurs bienvenue
il n'y a rien de mieux faire du cinéma
regardez on est là on a des ennemis et
je voudrais pas dieu qui nous sommes on
est intégré à pâques et pour tous par
toutes les côtes est et nord la dernière
romantique on résiste et non pas humain
voyez ce qui se passe dans le monde
était là je suis sérieux il ya des
guerres déjà qui s'insultent qu'ils
s'attaquent l'âme faire nous dans un
studio en l1 comme une forteresse
on continue à raconter n'importe quoi
protégé par son père entrer dans les
studios à hyères dehors c'est l'enfer et
m'ont hélas a détendu
si dieu existe qu'aimeriez vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire salut
l'a6 ou restez vous descendez la
personne voilà je vous rappelle que
france 2 a décidé de bouleverser ses
programmes ce soir et diffusera vers 23
heures le film d'ettore scola une
journée particulière avec sophia loren
auparavant notre magazine envoyé spécial
avec un reportage passionnant sur les
manuscrits de la mer morte est sûre le
groupe des sales gosses à la
saint-urbain honneur aux chérubins
dernier journal vers 12h45 en compagnie
de philippe lefait dans un instant la
météo sophie davant et le pain route de
valérie maurice demain à 13h retrouver
patrick chesnais à 20 heures daniel
bilalian je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée en vous laissant méditer ce
proverbe particulièrement dédié ce soir
à marcello mastroianni dans le soleil
s'éclipse ou envoie la grandeur
excellente soirée merci